what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today we will be
talking about the latest developments in
the block clover story including more
major twists and turns that have just
been revealed in the story itself and it
seems to me that these revelations are
clear clues for where the story is about
to go from here we just got some major
information about what really happened
in the past few chapters but we also got
some clues for what the next arc of the
black clover story will be and that is
exactly what I will be talking about in
this video if you enjoy the black clover
content on this channel you can leave a
like to let me know and if you happen to
be new to anime uproar please don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification valve this video is brought
to you by the anime uproar patrons we
don't have a sponsor for this video or
anything like that but I want to give a
quick thank you to all of our patrons
the patreon has been growing which means
a lot I'll talk about our patrons more
at the end of the video and now let's
get into it please be advised that this
video is dealing with the latest
developments in the black Lora stories
so manga spoilers will be included
proceed with caution you have been
warned as we learned recently king
julius did indeed manage to come back to
life after his battle with Patri
although he somehow shrunk in the
process by which I mean he now looks
much younger than he did before Yami
echos the feelings of many of us when he
expresses his confusion saying that
Julius was definitely 100% dead and that
he Yami had been infused with new
determination and resolved because of
Julius his death and the
responsibilities that Julius had
entrusted to Yami upon his death
Yami is definitely glad to see Julius
again and he is happy that Julius isn't
really dead but he is also confused
about how Julius managed to survive why
he became younger and how it is possible
that Julius will now seemingly get to
live out his life all over again as I
said Yami's words echo what many of us
felt in the previous chapters we felt
that Julius his sacrifice although
deeply tragic because Julius is such a
great and likable character was an
important emotional moment in the story
Julius his sacrifice had a lot of
meaning in terms of the narrative and as
Yami said the failure to prevent them
was
King's death had a deep impact on every
member of the magic nights from Yami to
austa and beyond the fact that it has
now been suddenly revealed that Julius
isn't really dead after all
after everything that we just went
through in the story does feel a bit
unsatisfying to some fans and I can
definitely understand that however as we
learned in Chapter 215 Julius is facing
repercussions for reviving himself and
major changes are about to take place
inside the clover kingdom whether we
like it or not after Yami has his brief
moment with chibi Julius William Vaughn
Jones breaks down in tears
clearly overcome with regret over the
fact that he allowed poetry to control
his body which enabled poetry to kill
Julius in the first place
Julius seems to be in a very forgiving
mood towards William and while this is
definitely consistent with Julius as
character and what we know about him so
far Yami again echos my own feelings
when he asked Julius if he isn't going
to easy on William after all William
allowed poetry to attack the entire
clover kingdom and hurt many innocent
people Julius says that he was the one
who invited William to join the magic
Knights and he was the one who appointed
him as captain he was also the one who
lost the fight against poetry so Julius
believes that some of the responsibility
for how everything turned out actually
falls on him Julius asks William if he
is willing to face the consequences of
his actions and keep pressing forward as
a magic knight and William breaks down
and pledges his grimoire to Julius and
the kingdom truly this time personally I
do think that Julius is being too
forgiving with William I'm not saying
that William can't repent and make up
for what he's done and he clearly does
feel a lot of remorse for his actions
but I don't think that he should be
forgiven so quickly I think William must
make amends first and take some form of
punishment
I mean sure give him a second chance but
I don't think William should be allowed
to go back to being the captain of the
highest-ranked magic knight squad right
away just like that
I think that first William has to prove
that he has changed that he has taken
responsibility for his actions and that
he is willing to work hard to gain back
everyone's trust acting like nothing
happened and just letting William go
back to his former position is too
lenient in my opinion but let me know
what you guys think what do you think
should happen to William and should he
be punished in some way or
forgiving outright chibi Julius then
goes on to address hasta noel meemaw
science' cray
Julius says that as things stand they
have three problems the first problem is
that the wizard king is gone now of
course we know that Julius isn't
actually dead
but as I predicted in my previous
blackboard video Julius has lost much of
his magic power and his grimoire has
been reduced to only one page
this means that he is no longer nearly
as strong as he once was and he will now
face serious challenges from potential
rivals for the position of wizard king
especially among the hardline Nobles who
want to make sure that only those with
royal blood
hold the position of wizard king when
asked by asta how he managed to survive
and why he is now so much younger
Julius explains that during his secret
magical wanderings he came across an
ancient magic storage technology that
was left behind by ancient mages the
name of this magic item or technology is
apparently Swallowtail and Sacre looks
understandably surprised when she hears
this because her family name is actually
Swallowtail in her character profile
that was recently released along with
volume 21 of the manga it is revealed
that sack Reyes full name is Sacre
Swallowtail it appears to Swallowtail
was one of the magic tools that Sucre
and Lumiere created together five
hundred years ago and Julia states that
his time magic and swallowtail were very
compatible so he managed to store his
own time and magic in the crest on his
forehead little by little and he could
then use this time that he had stored to
do things over in case something bad
happened to him
Swallowtail appears to have been shown
in the flashback in chapter 204 an item
that looks almost exactly like
Swallowtail is also shown in chapter 205
this circular object was apparently used
by the devil to help initiate the elf
massacre on page 7 of chapter 205 sakra
tries to use the magic item that looks
very much like Swallowtail to absorb the
demon lifts magic but at that point the
magic item breaks it could not absorb
all of the magic it is likely that at
some point Julius founded fragments of
this same item and repaired it with his
time magic
or he found another item that Lumi Aaron
Sacre created that was very similar to
the one that the devil used during the
massacre however the process did not
work exactly how Julius had planned and
when he finally decided to use the
stored magic to save himself after being
killed by Patri he was brought back at a
very young age
according to Julius this was the oldest
that he could make himself
Julius then notices Sacre whom he hadn't
seen in her human form before and he can
tell right away that she possesses
unique and interesting magic Julius has
sheer giddiness over Sakura's magic
proves to everyone that he is indeed the
same old wizard King despite having the
appearance of a much younger person
Julius then goes on to identify two more
problems and these two problems are
closely related to one another
Julius says that if nothing changes the
clover kingdom will be destroyed by
other nations the second problem is that
hasta will die everyone is naturally
shocked by this revelation and this is
where the chapter ends with another
massive twist and yet more unanswered
questions I definitely saw the first of
these three problems coming Julius is
now like 13 years old and his grimoire
is back to a single page so it was
evident from the previous chapter that
he would not be as strong now as he was
before the second problem is not a huge
shock either the clover kingdom has
already battled other kingdoms like the
diamond kingdom in the past so there's
no surprise that they may have to fight
against the rival kingdoms in the future
but I have to admit that I did not see
the third problem coming I did not
predict that Julius would just come out
and say that
hasta is going to die but what does
Julius mean when he says that hasta will
die to me this sounds like the setup for
a new arc in the story we've all been
thinking about where the plot would go
from here seeing a softwear over 200
chapters we've been focused on the elf
saga but it appears that Julius just
gave us a glimpse of where the story
will go next first of all Julius will no
longer be as overpowered as he once was
this means that the clover kingdom will
no longer be able to rely on an epically
powerful protector who uses time magic
this may lead to rival nations deciding
that this is a good time to attack the
kobra kingdom especially now that the
kingdom has been we
and as a result of the massive battle
that just took place against the elves
and the devil
the clover kingdom may also be weakened
by the power vacuum left by Julius
if Julius is no longer strong enough to
serve as the wizard king there will be a
power vacuum as various factions and
mages try to get their hands on the
wizard king position this may lead to
yet more fighting between the nobles and
commoners and between various factions
within these larger groups and that will
make the clover Kingdom less unified and
therefore more vulnerable to attack
finally why in the world would Asta's
life be in danger right now
ASSA has only been getting stronger and
stronger so how could he be about to die
this has to be related to his anti magic
and the demon inside his grimoire either
Asta's magic will make him a target for
powerful enemies who are scared of his
power or potentially want to take the
power for themselves or Asta's use of
anti magic is actually slowly killing
him without anyone realizing it in terms
of external threats after playing a key
role in defeating the word magic devil
hasta has proven himself to be very
dangerous for the demon species so if
there are other Devils from the
alternate dimension out there they would
probably want to take out hasta so that
he can't use anti magic to take them out
instead alternatively if someone from
say a rival Kingdom has heard about
astaxanthin ajik they may try to get
their hands on austin's grimoire and
harness that power for themselves even
if asta dies in the process but we
cannot forget about internal threats
either we now know that the demon inside
of asters grimoire is from the same
alternate dimension as the word magic
devil and we've known for a while that
Asta's demon has tried to possess
Austin's body in the past in the recent
fight against the word magic Devil
Asta's demon definitely helped hasta but
could it be that this was just part of
his plan and the demon's true intentions
are to slowly kill all fastest
consciousness so that he can possess
Austin's body if the demons true
intentions are sinister and he does at
some point managed to take over Austin's
body then we can definitely look forward
to an epic new arc that turns our hero
hasta into an overpowered
demon-possessed villain or perhaps using
anti magic isn't as harmless Frost as we
thought hasta is able to use anti magic
because he doesn't have any magic of his
own but if
anyone else tries to use anti-magic they
will be drained of their power but what
if using anta magic to such an extreme
extent as hasta has been doing in the
recent arks actually causes lasting harm
to Aust as well we just didn't realize
it right away because he doesn't have
any magic is it possible that using anti
magic is slowly killing asta and that is
why Julius said that if nothing changes
asta will die we can't know for sure at
this point but it is clear that we are
now being slowly teased into a brand new
arc that takes the story beyond the elf
saga obviously I don't think that Austin
will actually die but I did find the
ending of this chapter to be a good plot
twist that completely changes the game
out of nowhere let me know what you guys
think about these new developments do
you like this new direction that the
story appears to be taking and why do
you think that Julius said that asta is
going to die did Julius see the future
did he learn of an existing threat on
Austin's life or something else entirely
let me know down in the comments I
always love hearing from you if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more black clover content on this
channel you can leave a like to let me
know and if you're new to anime uproar
please don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you could be
notified whenever a new video goes live
feel free to hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime out for all the
latest black clover news and updates I
want to give a huge thank you to all of
our anime upper patrons for supporting
our work and making our work possible a
special thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings eldress and on Hell crews another
massive thank you to our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including baby ray ace
ingrid ah al Olin Adam Maddy Mac
makoto-kun and keelon and finally at the
very pinnacle of interdimensional
greatness a tier reserved only for
legends a massive thank you to Reagan
Harrison and Lord naksan or disciples Oh
Lord to ego himself if you feel that our
content provides value for you when you
want to support more be sure to check
out our patreon link in the description
you
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see our space cowboys
[Music]